I'll helpful advice with Bobby kalila at
Chris what doing email and then will you
try your best to respond
it's called unhelpful advice you don't
have to be hello Tiger belly my name is
jerimae and I'm from Brazil and I have a
girlfriend
we're both young 19 years old for me 18
year old 18 years old for her and I'm
extremely jealous of her and her
ex-boyfriend dudes that she gets laid
with I was a virgin I was a virgin until
I met her and I can't stand she talking
about her past sexual relations I don't
know if that happens because I was a
virgin but I wish that some of her
experiences of BDSM she should have done
only with me I think that I'm selfish
and need to see some professional help
because the feeling it's the same that
if I was cheated I feel depressive
extremely sad can you help me with some
advice I know that you're young I know
that we're young but she really is the
woman of my life I've been with other
girls but we have never had sex thanks
love you Bobby you lost his virginity to
this girl and she keeps talking about
her previous partner I can't change you
have the facts you have to accept the
situation because there's nothing you
can do about it no what he could do
about it is hey listen lady I love you I
don't want to hear about your [ __ ]
because I'm not emotionally mature I'm
not I'm not ready to hear all of it like
you and I we talk about [ __ ] openly
because we laugh about it I'm 31 year 45
we we've seen a bit right but when
you're 19 you're not emotionally
equipped to deal with or imagining your
partner being with other people
especially BDSM I get what he's doing I
guess what I'm saying yeah it's um he
loves her so much and he he hates the
fact that some other man you know I mean
every 19 years yeah it's funny because
when you're 19 what did he say I know
we're young but she really is the woman
in my life like I think back to when I
was 19 and I was saying the same exact
[ __ ] thing about I can't even
remember her name now you know and and
so I get where this kids at and I can
totally empathize with him but dude it's
gonna change I also think that
jealousy is almost inescapable you're
going to get through you're going to go
through a window a few years where
you're just the most jealous person on
earth and you're gonna break out of it
at some point some people take longer
some people say Josh I could still feel
jealous really yeah he's not jealous I'm
not jealous at all I'm still a little no
I wish I could be jealous me I love you
no it just means he's been through a lot
I just don't get jealous I if you
cheated on me there'll be wrath like a
massive rad thing you won't survive yeah
you want survive it but it'll just be so
devastating that you'll be like what the
[ __ ] happens um so many but but I know
that you won't do that so I'm fine yeah
you if you read a club and you some guy
you know me trying to hit on you I've
seen it
guys come up to you're going it doesn't
make me jealous at all and and then if
they look at me and they go why you with
this little piece of [ __ ] I'm [ __ ]
magic pure magic I also don't don't do
things to incite any type of jealousy
I'm thinking I'm great babe give some
credit to me yeah give her some credit I
want to hear about this really go ahead
about you - where'd you meet you're so
great we met oh yeah you tell me we
already [ __ ] told you I'm trying to
come up with an alternate story that
other people might believe but I also
want to plug your I want your Instagram
your Twitter to go up yeah thank you
what is that so nice okay my Instagram
at y tau wi t Oh W okay okay Instagram
that's Instagram
Oh Twitter is my name at chris wachowsky
wi t aske okay when you in if you do
follow chris do not follow his
girlfriend yes in fact if you're
following or unfollow even the playing
field even the playing field
no I love her so much she's great I just
wanna say that it was a pleasure come
back I want to come back
it's a lot to dig it I think we still
have we all been to together I think
this is the tip of the iceberg yes it's
the bottom and we learned a lot from you
with the masses we got to get through of
the iceberg where do you have a show
right now it's none of your business
what time were we at now we're long
pretty long what is it our something all
right 15 good that was an hour yeah
[Music]